a new charter school is opening its
doors in north las vegas
construction is already underway and
it's set to make its debut this fall
madison kimbrough has the details for us
yes this is exciting news for parents
all over the valley and you don't even
have to live in the district to attend
and with the hopes of kids joining back
into the classroom this fall
this is a great option civica career and
collegiate academy is a tuition free k
through 7th grade public charter school
located right off of east
cary avenue and civic center drive in
north las vegas
civica is now enrolling students with
the hope of expanding further down the
line
all the way to the 12th grade civica
will offer individualized instruction
stem curriculum hands-on learning and
leadership and character development
programs
for students targeting what they want to
do and are truly interested
in we spoke with the principal on how
she believes it's the perfect time to
open
and give students the interactions and
connections they need
i call our civica career and collegiate
academy in north las vegas the north
star
and we are just excited to
engage with our families keep them
involved make sure that our students
are career and college ready this
charter school is based in florida and
it has been in the works for three years
to bring it to north las vegas
they're also currently looking for
staffing for this fall providing job
opportunities
to the valley open enrollment runs
through the end of february and there's
a lottery on march first but spaces are
limited we'll have all the details
up on our website reporting in north las
vegas madison kimbrough 8 news now